There have to be more tombs
out there in need of raiding,
so why didn't 2018's "Tomb Raider" ever lead to
another adventure? You can thank Amazon for that.
"Tomb Raider" was one of the hottest video game
series of the 1990s, centering on Lara Croft,
a relic-hunting adventurer. The first film
adaptation of the "Tomb Raider" franchise
was Angelina Jolie's 2001 adventure flick. It
earned a healthy $273 million at the box office,
a solid take for a turn-of-the-millennium
action movie and enough to get a sequel
quickly greenlit. In 2018, the baton was passed
to Alicia Vikander's "Tomb Raider" reboot,
and it earned almost the exact
same amount, yet there's been
no follow-up since. But the reason why
is more complicated than ticket sales.
A sequel was in the works for a 2021
release, but it quickly hit a snag with
the outbreak of COVID-19 in early 2020,
just as things were apparently ramping
up. Vikander was repeatedly asked about the
sequel, and in a chat with Collider in 2021,
she seemed unsure if it was still
going to happen, explaining:
"Pre-COVID, I would've said yes. And now I think
it's a yes still. It's not greenlit, but the
script is in the making. And I think everyone is
excited, and I would love to revisit Lara again."
Those delays may have cost
them a sequel, because in 2022,
Amazon acquired MGM, which forced the
franchise into a complicated legal limbo,
and the rights lapsed. An anonymous
studio source told The Wrap:
"There was a pre-negotiated ticking clock that had
been agreed to, and there was no way to rescue it
in time. [MGM] asked the rights holders for
more time, but their patience had run out."
Even though "Tomb Raider" met with decidedly mixed
reviews upon its release, it has achieved a mild
cult status with fans who would love to see
Vikander back as Lara Croft in a second movie.
And it seems the filmmakers and its cast would
love nothing more than to reunite for another
go. In 2021, "Lovecraft Country" creator Misha
Green signed up to write and direct a sequel.
"Howdy Tomb Raider fans. My name is Misha Green
and I'm the writer and director of
the upcoming Tomb Raider movie.”
Vikander seemed particularly pumped
about the prospect of working with her,
telling Entertainment Weekly in 2021:
"I hope we go and make another
movie. Because of the pandemic,
we had plans of shooting this film,
and now it's been one and a half years,
but Misha Green is on board, and
she's writing a draft right now."
Ever hopeful, Vikander seemed ready to strap on
the guns and get back to adventuring, adding:
"It would be so amazing if we get to go
and do this very big-ass film together,
going to kick some ass in front of
the camera and behind the camera."
A year later, though, Vikander's tone shifted,
and she cautioned that the odds were stacked
against them, telling MovieZine in 2022:
"I'm good at going back to that role, and it
would mean a lot of training. Now it's a lot
of talk considering that Amazon has bought MGM,
and after the pandemic there is so much politics,
so right now I actually do not
really know what is happening."
If there's going to be a "Tomb Raider"
sequel, it would of course have to star
Alicia Vikander. As far back as 2019, with
a sequel already in early development,
there wasn't actually concrete word on
whether Vikander would reprise the role,
with People reporting that it was still
"unclear" whether she'd be back. But
that question was answered when the actress
officially signed up, and she began speaking
about the sequel publicly. Sadly, most of
her comments were regarding its long delay.
Beyond Vikander, there isn't much known about
who else from the cast might've reappeared
in this proposed sequel, though an unverified
report in 2020 did suggest that Kristen Scott
Thomas would return and that she'd have a
much meatier role. The actress had played
a smaller part as Ana Miller, Lara's mentor and a
colleague of her father, in the 2018 film. Ana is
a bigger bad in the video games, and according
to the rumor, she would have been bumped up to
the main villain for the sequel, which had
been teased at the close of the first film.
"You can pick up where you left off."
"Tomb Raider" was helmed in 2018 by a relatively
unknown Norwegian filmmaker named Roar Uthaug,
who a few years later directed the cult
hit "Troll." The script was penned by
Geneva Robertson-Dworet in her feature film
debut, alongside co-writers Evan Daugherty
and Alastair Siddons. Robertson-Dworet went on
to work on "Captain Marvel," but neither she
nor Uthaug were expected to return for
the second "Tomb Raider" film after it
began development. Instead, writer Amy Jump
was signed in 2019 to pen the second film,
and Ben Wheatley inked a deal
to sit in the director's chair.
But as the delays on the film began to pile up,
the studio made significant changes to the crew
behind the camera, which saw both Amy Jump and
Ben Wheatley dismissed from the project. Replacing
them was Misha Green, who was announced to
both write and direct the sequel in 2021,
though no reason was given as to the
swap in filmmakers. Nevertheless,
Green got right to work, and by May, she was
telling her following on Twitter that the
first draft of the script was complete but that
there was "still a long journey to production."
"Long," in this instance, was
a hell of an understatement.
"You might as well tie a stone to
your foot and jump off the boat now."
Though it took more than a year after "Tomb
Raider" was released before the studio was
ready to commit to a sequel, they finally did
put the wheels in motion in 2019. In fact,
rumor has it that the "Tomb Raider" sequel
came fairly close to beginning production. A
November 2019 report from HN Entertainment
claimed that Vikander was signed on,
the script was ready to go, and the studio
was locking down locations for shooting.
Per that same report — which was seemingly never
confirmed by any of the major trades — MGM studios
was preparing to bring the production back
to the U.K., where much of the first movie
was filmed. Warner Bros.' Leavesden Studios was
even said to be the place where they would set
up shop for the sequel before it all fell apart.
What's known for a fact is that this version of
the movie was supposed to start shooting
in early 2020, although pandemic-related
shutdowns forced the project to be put on
hold, and then its release date was taken
off the calendar altogether. It wouldn't be
until 2021 that it got back up and running.
By then, Green was the writer and director of
record, and her version of the film was also
further along than some fans may realize. As
it happens, it even had a title, "Tomb Raider:
Obsidian," and Vikander was expressing excitement
over an imminent production start that never came.
Nobody but those involved know what the sequel
would have been about when it was under the
stewardship of writer Amy Jump and director Ben
Wheatley. However, some word has trickled out
over the years of what might have happened in
the version written by Green, cobbled together
from various tidbits that leaked during its
development and after the film was shuttered.
In addition to talk that Kristen Scott
Thomas would return in a bigger role as
the main villain of the film, audiences also got a
brief glimpse of some of the action in late 2022,
when storyboard artist Jake Lunt Davies posted
a series of images that he'd created for the
project on Twitter. What they revealed
didn't give away too much of the plot,
but they did showcase a pulse-pounding
sequence that may have kicked off the
story, with a daring attack on Croft
Manor carried out by shadowy agents.
Given the ending of the 2018 "Tomb
Raider" — and the rumored larger role
for Ana Williams — it's possible this raid
was orchestrated by Lara Croft's mentor,
sparking a quest that would take her to
various locations to get to the truth.
If there's anything still standing in the way of
a direct sequel to 2018's "Tomb Raider," it isn't
the pandemic, problems with the script,
or scheduling with the actors. Instead,
it's the fact that a reboot of the
franchise was announced in early 2023.
This stems from MGM's loss of the rights
following their acquisition by Amazon,
with an apparent bidding war taking place
for the chance to start from scratch.
"Blockbuster news shaking Hollywood this morning.
Amazon buying MGM studios for 8.5 billion bucks."
The winners of that bidding war were of course
Amazon, who quickly announced grand plans for
a total reboot of the movie with a new actor
taking over for Vikander. The deal was a big
one for the streaming service, which includes
much more than just the rights to make a feature
film. And while numbers weren't announced,
The Hollywood Reporter suggested it only
fell a little short of their gargantuan deal
for "The Lord of The Rings." The announcement
came on the heels of the news that Amazon would be
getting into the video game publishing business,
and it would be putting out the next Tomb Raider
console game from developer Crystal Dynamics.
Details at this time are still sketchy,
with no writer announced for the film,
let alone a director or star. But that
doesn't mean that Amazon hasn't started
work on the project, and they have, in fact,
made bigger plans that could see an explosion of
"Tomb Raider" across multiple media platforms.
After snagging the rights to a "Tomb Raider"
adaptation, the folks at Amazon have revealed
they'll be crafting a big-screen reboot ... but
that isn't all. The film will be just one part
of a larger tapestry, and they have plans
to turn the franchise into a full-fledged
cinematic universe. To make that happen,
they have announced that a "Tomb Raider"
TV series is in the works as a streaming
original, with plans for the show and film
to be tightly integrated with both each other
and the already-announced video game relaunch.
Even more exciting is that spearheading the effort
behind the scenes will be Phoebe Waller-Bridge,
the three-time Emmy Award-winning creator
and writer of "Fleabag," star of "Indiana
Jones and the Dial of Destiny," and
co-writer of the 2021 James Bond film
"No Time to Die." According to the trades,
Waller-Bridge will write the series — but
is unlikely to be involved in the film —
and while many fans may have jumped to the
conclusion that she might play Lara Croft
too, that doesn't appear to be the case.
One actor who has stepped up to volunteer for the
title role is Michaela Jae
Rodriguez, who told Variety:
"I would like to tackle a role like Lara
Croft. I would love to do that because I
have the badassness and sex appeal to make people
love it. If not, I would also love to be Lara
Croft's right-hand girl who gets just as much
airtime and is right next to her killing it."
With a cinematic universe on its way that
will reboot the franchise with an all-new
cast and crew, it might seem like a sequel
to 2018's "Tomb Raider" has no chance of
ever seeing the light of day. But if one steps
back and takes stock of the Hollywood landscape,
they'll see that a return to that
universe isn't really far-fetched,
and it could actually still happen,
even if it's not anytime soon.
After all, recent films like "Spider-Man:
No Way Home" and "The Flash" have seen the
return of actors who audiences thought
they'd said goodbye to decades ago,
with both Tobey Maguire and Michael
Keaton returning as Spider-Man and Batman.
"...verse Angelina Jolie.
That would be a cool film."
And while there's very, very little chance that
Amazon would use a multiverse gimmick to have
previous Lara Crofts meet — although that's what
studios all seem to think the fans want — the
idea of returning to the continuity of a previous
movie even after a reboot isn't without precedent
itself. The "Terminator" and "Halloween"
franchises both did just that, after all.
From the sounds of it, even star
Alicia Vikander would still be up
for reprising the role years down the
line. Vikander told Variety in 2023:
"For me, that was another one of those childhood
dreams — to portray an action character was
awesome and beyond what I ever thought I would do.
And I think the physical part is something that I
really enjoyed. So, yeah, if another opportunity
like that came again, I'll be interested."